hi I'm Andre kuznia executive director
hold for research for document systems
I'm here to give a talk on how we are
doubling down on our notebook technology
going forward and pretty much
demonstrating all the features of
deployment options that we have
alright let's get started here so I'm
Andre kuznia
director of document and media systems
at Wolfram for years I give talks on
some of the side methods or side usage
of our notebook technologies for
deployment particularly for applications
and particularly based on the CDF
concept that we had been pushing for a
little over a decade now and while that
concept still stands it's a it's a
descriptor of the underlying
specification and technology that makes
notebooks work as Steven indicated in
his keynote last night
we've really come around to the world
accepting that concept of notebooks and
embracing it and since you know we kind
of started that party we don't want to
be left out and we really feel like as a
you know as a branding exercise it's
really more important to stick with
notebooks and and put them front and
center again so we're doubling down on
that concept and as I had indicated last
year you know we're we're essentially
joining a growing group of of notebook
technologies or usage on the world I'm
pointing out here this the blog post
from Steven that promotes where we stand
now with our emphasis on how you can
readily publish if you want to use the
word publish deploy notebooks online on
the web pretty much as simple as
choosing a menu item and pushing the
button and putting it up so you know
this is a case where a whole lot of work
goes into making something look simple
right and easy breezy and it's
particularly the case that with the way
you know others have been bringing
notebooks out into the world they're
just doing it on the web and for us you
know we we've taken a bit of extra time
to get to that point because we don't
just want static documents on the web
you know or we don't just want static
HTML with bits of interactive code on
the web we want the entire notebook
experience to be available to people by
default that means for the the free
usage very much like it's been in the in
when we've used the player you put it up
you've got interactive through
manipulates and and other kinds of
standard things that have always been
true when you use CDF player on the
desktop remains true in the cloud and as
long as you know you're using this
material for your use for the public
good we're we're you know we don't have
a problem with it we want everybody to
start using this stuff so this talk is
is you know just breaking down some of
the details the steps Stephen kind of
showed this stuff I'm just highlighting
points in his blog that are worth noting
particularly that even though you know
we're putting notebooks in the cloud
they're not always a hundred percent I
mean I certainly am frontline of hearing
from people who may have issues when
they try things and the important fact
is that you know being in the cloud
doesn't mean you have to use it on the
web it's there people can see it you you
you see the notebook if there's an issue
with it is still downloadable and you
can still get the usual desktop
experience you always want and so
there's still always the player right so
the player concept is is kind of where
it's always been in terms of you know
it's a binary you come to our site you
you grab the file you download it we've
made that as simple as possible we don't
require anybody to register themselves
you know if you if you've got users who
are shy you know
you can tell them they don't even have
to give us their email they can get the
player that's not a problem for us
now if for some reason they do want to
give us their email or tell us a little
bit about them because we will ask those
questions we follow the protocol
established by the gdpr rules from
Europe so you know everything about
checking the box that says we're making
you aware that we are keeping track of
this information is all being built into
our download form but it's that's all
entirely optional you could just go
there and grab it so the I think that
the main point about where we are with
player and notebooks right now is that
the behavior of a notebook that you save
from Mathematica without saying anything
doing anything special is the same as it
would have been in the past where we
asked you to export it or save as CDF
right we made you go to an extra step
because we were being a little bit over
I would say overly protective of what
we're letting people put out in the
world and the notebooks had to be signed
you know by a hash that you know gave it
a secure identity that let our player
recognize that it came from us right
we're not doing that right now
so what that means is that there's two
aspects of that but the simplest fact is
that it just works so yay great right
I'll get to what that means in terms of
what we used to make claims about how
our licensing work for CDF again that's
simpler now - it's still the case that
you can upgrade the player to play a pro
that's the concept we had for a long
time which is you might have users that
are willing to pay a per seat of this
player that is enhanced for more
capabilities and you get just with the
plane player level so that still works
and for now it's still true that we have
enterprise capability of exporting
notebooks and and that will still be for
now
indicated or or saved as a CDF file
because that we still have a lot of
deployment code functionality for for
doing deployments we don't want to tear
things apart for people who are doing
application development right and it
still works the same way for that yeah I
mean John is here from the front end
group and and we we're still backward
compatible to Ma files right and just
like that so yeah so we you won't lose
out on any of that iOS you know is it's
pretty cool right now that we've got a
player working both on iPad and on
iPhones and that you can open the
notebook there but iOS the default
behaviors that there's no interaction
but if you've got to log in because
you've got a cloud subscription with us
you'll you can log in on your player and
you'll automatically have the
interactive features or you yourself or
people that you're sending it to can do
a one-time in-app purchase for nine
bucks or ten bucks and they'll get
interactivity with any notebook they
ever get you know it's not just for the
one time will give you the interactivity
to but but it's I didn't really want to
bring that up exactly because it's a
little confusing because it doesn't give
you more it just it gives you the
interactivity but yes so you can provide
it to people if you're an enterprise
user and it'll just work so manipulates
and and graphics and things like that
but not the normal enterprise level
features which is a you know interacting
with your with your system right with
your with your hard drive you know that
kind of thing is still sandbox dinner
and our apps
alright so cloud app is also available
as a way to use notebooks
so you can actually construct a notebook
using cloud app on your phone I can't
you know it's it's supposed to be UX
optimized for mobile use I can't say
that's the most realistic thing to do
but you know if you ever have to jump in
on something around it something you can
so back to the point about notebooks
just work
the rules for those are simpler now
we're really just making this ding ssin
between whether you're you're using it
personally and and keeping it publicly
available or if you're doing commercial
distribution you know so if you're a
publisher and you're putting something
out in the world where you obviously
want to control all the aspects of it
then that's arrangement you make with us
as a revenue share or a purchase of
seeds and again as I mentioned
Enterprise continues to go out the door
as Enterprise CDF when you want those
kinds of features were we're gonna make
a transition and a few more releases
ahead where eventually will enterprise
signing will be done to regular
notebooks and we just have to get the UX
sorted out for that so that that's clear
for everybody we've got a page online
this is very small going into just
explaining the licensing and we've got
some of the same facts that we've had in
the past for when we explain things for
CDF ok let's talk about how we're
deploying notebooks these days so one of
the coolest things of course you know
cloud but that we've got this embedder
it's a this is coded in JavaScript and
so and and the idea behind it is to go
beyond just basic iframes if you guys
know HTML a little bit you know an
iframe is a container that cuts itself
into a web page and you can put any HTML
URL like any document that's served
the web inside that iframe so that's a
way to say you support embedding but we
we really want the integration of
notebooks into your HTML to be smoother
than that you know we don't want it to
be in such a rigorous container that
causes its own scrolling behaviors
within a window that is separately
scrolling it's kind of clunky it's it's
very old-school so I think the impact of
this javascript embedding feature is
going to be great it gives you know
particularly publishers and and people
who are working hard to make really nice
deployments it gives them a lot of
flexibility and you're gonna see that in
lots of the things we've been putting
out in the world like for example
notebook archive so you know when
Stephen was showing this last night he
had some trouble I don't know why his
thumbnails didn't render but you know
we've been collecting a lot of material
we announced this year or so ago and
building up what's available now many of
you are old timers and have a lot of
content and you might find some of your
stuff from math source but you'll have
to look for it and see if it's there and
if you don't see it immediately it might
be because it's old and we've got a
switch here that says include legacy
content so that even older stuff will
show up I don't know if I made that
switch work successfully here because
maybe there wasn't any but the point is
if you're not seeing and immediately
look at that at switching the search
results here okay so well actually I
before I jump away from that I should
just show one of these so again this is
embedded separately from you know the
iframe method it gives us a little more
control and I'll show you some better
examples but in all cases we always want
to emphasize you can download what's
there you can open it into your own
cloud account and there's going to be
other things that show up here the
submission process lets you set
the terms of use you know if you're
somebody who wants to reserve the rights
here it means that you're submitting it
for the archive but only for the archive
and it's not for anybody to just grab it
and redistribute it from there but if
you're if you like the idea that hey
this is an open-access kind of document
I want anybody to have it anywhere you
can choose different rights of
submission this is if you're familiar
with archive.org you know it's not that
different from preprint servers that
have been doing this for a long time as
we've seen demonstrations we we've been
updating these to function essentially
as embedded content as well in this case
you get a preview animation of what's
what's there and then you see the actual
embedded cloud object come in and now
this is the thing and I can interact
with and again embed code is provided
here so this is the JavaScript and
better it's copy to clipboard or if you
want to do the iframe method that's
available to you here too you can also
you know copy the code to the clipboard
paste it in your notebook Stephen those
to do that source variations available
here and again download the desktop so
you know as a resource
you know our demonstration site is kind
of like our premier archive
demonstrating all the bells and whistles
are the kinds of things we like to do
and offer so you know if you've got
stuff you want to submit there it gets
the full-blown treatment yeah I mean
that's the that's the idea behind it and
now if if you've got notebooks that are
not that then use the archive you know
use the notebook archive and all of that
getting point to things that way so
Stephen had shown this example we are
putting notebooks in the cloud again
that's being done with that Java Script
embedding and what that means is you can
control whether or not there's any kind
of visible border or whether you're
showing cell brackets or not and that
the content Scrolls with the window as
it's gross
it's integrated it feels like part of
the whole thing and this is you know
alive manipulate as well whoops I showed
that scroll the way too fast you know
rotatable graphics so I just want to
demonstrate real fast that process of
putting something in here is pretty
straightforward
so the point being that you know when
you start a discussion here you know put
in your title whatever it is and we now
have in this ad notebook button we're
calling it beta because we're we've just
got this up for everybody to try it here
it's pretty straightforward but what
you're pasting here is the the cloud
object from when you publish your your
notebook so I could show that real fast
so let me demonstrate that point real
quickly so you know the point being here
I want to publish that
so let's publish it to cloud and I just
go ahead copy to clipboard
the thing that I've just published and
let's get back to this and I'm gonna go
ahead and paste that in here and so this
is previewed down here and I should
throw this away after today it makes me
look a little foolish but I'm gonna go
ahead and publish it and I have to do
which I have to pick one okay I'm
sharing a big idea here just okay 3d
printing you never have so okay thanks
about Vitaly czar community director so
I have to do a better description okay
so testing this for the conference
alright let's see how that goes hey
there it is it's even got my picture on
it so yeah so there you go and you know
what the idea here that we like is
because there's already metadata at the
top of the notebook you're publishing
for the the community post itself you
don't necessarily have to reiterate the
title and your name and all that stuff
the post is just the body content now
we'll make this a little more
sophisticated you know at some point you
know people when you're writing a
notebook you always put a title you know
you always put everything at the top
that you want we're gonna make this
sophisticated enough to recognize that
that's there and if it's duplicated in
your post we'll just remove it you know
but that's gonna take a little more time
but you know this is a big deal and this
is gonna have a really nice impact I
think so alright let's get back to where
I was
you and your math source you guys yes
well as I indicated we are mining math
source for the notebook archive so it's
not gonna go into community I don't
Batali I don't think you guys heard
trying to dig stuff out of mass source
for that that's kind of up to users to
put it there right yeah so I want to
show what we're doing on github as well
and John is here he might you know take
questions about that later if you all
want but so when putting notebook
content and github right now you do have
the means of making it more viewable
because of this github viewer feature
that is available as a form online to
exploit but I'm just showing it really
quickly in terms of looking at what's in
here I don't know how there you go so
you know this is all you know using
github as a way to access our stuff so
that I find pretty handy as well okay
and then let me talk quick the
capability is right if you go through
our form so let me speak quickly too
besides doing things online but you know
that is the way the future that's where
everybody goes
you know I've promoted at the conference
here pretty regularly this notion of a
portable CDF player and that's something
Mark and Arielle have done with their
data modeler product which is taking
since C well the Wolfram player since
the Wolfram player is is already
activated you know you don't have to
individually activate it it just runs on
your system you can distribute it with
all of your content with your full
application so so if you don't mind a
zip file or whatever or a thumb drive
that's got
potentially the player for every
platform you want to support so windows
and and Mac I'm the same thumb drive
along with all of your application
content and then this little a a little
bit of a Java applet we have that does
the right selecting of the player you
could stick that thumb drive in a
computer and run your application on any
machine right so it's a really nice
feature these guys particularly liked it
that's how they distribute their
application to their customers then
another concept we've been doing lately
is the idea of ebook distribution based
on notebooks that has a certain amount
of drm built into it and the way that
works for us is you essentially you get
at you you point to your you know you
sell a book on our store and when the
person buys it they get a download of
the book contents and they when they run
what's been downloaded they're asked for
their wolfram ID and the order number ID
and that is combined with the machine ID
so those three pieces of information
essentially lock the application to that
that computer now when i say lock it
just means that that we have encoded for
the benefit the author or the author
does it themselves certain aspects of
their notebooks that either obscure say
the style sheets so that what the
person's looking at isn't visible unless
it's properly activated or if they're
running a package you know dot m code it
can encode some of that so now people
can get around this I'm not making any
claims that this is like so secure that
nobody can break it but the point is
particularly for Keith's tryin that his
students needed to recognize that the
textbook he sold to them for use at his
school which is a site license for
Mathematica his students needed to
recognize that this was intellectual
property and that they shouldn't just
give copies of it to all our friends
right and and it's like a two-way street
you have to make a certain commitment to
protecting it and that communicates to
the customer that oh I get it
I'm not really allowed to steal this
right if they're gonna go to so much
trouble to reverse-engineer it well
they're clever and they're crooks right
so this has been working pretty well and
and I can recommend it wholeheartedly
for anybody who's got book content they
want to put out we can make this work
pretty well and in the case of Bruce
Schneider his content isn't even about
Mathematica it's just he liked it as a
deployment method for the content he
wanted to put out so it's a little bit
you know obscure for me to offer that up
as an example but it works for him you
know he was familiar with our language
and he just found it very practical well
if you're upgrading your machine it
might just be the case that that you
have to get in touch with us and we can
get you enough grade based on it this is
it's not I'm not proposing that this is
a solution that's gonna carry you for 10
years of product use right now these are
educators and it's for their students to
get by in a semester you know and it
goes quickly they they it's somewhat
disposable for their needs right as a
lot of textbook purchases are for
students I'm not saying it's that way
forever but that's kind of how we put it
together right now so all right so I'm
gonna wind down here but I just want to
give pointers out to the sort of updated
information we have everywhere online so
for for telling our story of notebooks
we put together this what we call a
feature set page that goes into detail
about our message about the features
about examples sort of called out how
our system works you know what you get
with it and everything and so if you
know if somehow you need to communicate
to people what you know our stuffs about
this is always a good place to go
similarly as we saw Stevens Ben
blogging about various things related
notebooks including a bunch of these
others that are relevant so it's you
know always worth going back to his blog
we have my team the one of the teams
that I run is our Wolfram u group and we
just completed a course on using
notebooks Dave wit off has been doing
some of what I think are best course
materials for these interactive MOOC
style courses where the idea is that
you're able to both watch videos and
follow along in notebook content that
you can copy and put in a scratch pad to
interact with while you're watching
things on video this interface allows
you to you know scale what you view and
everything it's fairly practical for
everybody we're we're putting a lot of
courses out this way and the ultimate
goal for us is to have a pretty
straightforward framework where you
provide the notebooks you provide the
videos you provide a manifest of you
know the structure of your course you
push a button and poosh it just puts it
all up on the cloud for you not there
yet but we'll be there shortly
all right I mentioned will from player
and iOS player and then Steven previewed
notebook addition for Wolfram Alpha
so of course story's not over more to
come but I'll stop there thank you
[Applause]
you